Yeah. It's that podcast is great because like,
we can talk about history and that's uncomfortable,
but because it's in the frame of history, it's like what? I'm not,
I'm not like whole stuff with like, um, uh, you know,
when everybody's mad about Christopher Columbus ripped down the statutes,
he w you know, he did do bad, but really, I mean,
he didn't kill as many native Americans as smallpox.
That's the truth that people don't want to talk about.
It's like the disease killed everybody. The disease killed the native Americans,
not the white settlers. They, they definitely killed some people,
but so did India, they made a good, they made a good tactics. Yeah. Yeah, no,
they definitely did. The days was killing them. And then,
and then the white man was like this, come on, tag me in. I finished them off,
but it's like, people love Gandhi. You know,
people love Gandhi and I it's great, but he also did have 12 year old wives.
So it's like,
you can say what you want about history and you could blame everything you want
on whatever group you want.
But the truth is that you're not going to probably like the truth,
but it's the truth. And that makes people uncomfortable.
So that's the P R podcast. Number one, it's comedy first. It's all about comedy.
So we lead with comedy,
but then you going to learn stuff about history that you could like regurgitate
at parties to conduct, to look somewhat cool. Honestly, I.
Get it out. Really,
all you need to know is like two sentences worth of knowledge about everything.
That's it, that's it.
You're just 1% more knowledgeable about everybody else on thing, you know, like,
I feel like Joe Rogan makes a living off it. We're just like,
he's so informed enough about everything. It's like, I'll believe you.
That's what it is. I mean, I automatically, you guys are smart now.
You know what I mean? It's like,
they know a little bit more about history than me solid. Yeah.
I know a couple of like famous guy quotes, like famous generals.
Cause you just regurgitate those and just be like, success is not final.
Failure is not fatal. It's the courage to continue that counts.
Winston Churchill, that's it blow job. And then they you.
You have chlamydia. That's what, it doesn't matter.
We're a comedy podcast that does history. Cause we both love history,
but we're basically doing the episode with the Wikipedia page, which is again,
one fan called us Wikipedia. Yeah. That was, have you ever donated to Wikipedia?
No.
That's the funniest thing. I love that every year when they're like,
can we have 30 cents? I'm like, get the outta here.
Wikipedia got me through college, got me through high school. I'm like,
do you want a dollar from me. You know,
I'm going to go do it right after this because I'm starting to feel really,
really, I mean, surely wildfires who actually donates.
I mean, they must get it right. I.
Don't know no idea.
They got to make it. If they made it easier,
I would donate the reason we don't donate. It's like I got to click.
I got to put my information like a demo Wikipedia. Yeah.
Yeah. Just do it with the Apple pay. Boom, Apple page. I mean,
I just pay for everything. I don't care. I just send it first time.
Probably like a month ago. I have no idea how much money in my bank account,
knowing how much money I spent over the last month. It's just like,
double-click, that's fine. Yeah. Just here,
scan my face and then take my money and yeah.
That's what it is. The, uh, what's your favorite? Like, uh, history time period.
Mine. Mine personally is world war two. Like a nah, no. I mean, I like.
I like world too, but it's the American revolution colonial colonial America,
1775 area to, or like 1799. I fought,
I fought with that. I really know a lot about that. And I love that.
I mean that part of history is wild. I mean, guys are in, you know,
tights and shoes and wigs fighting. Um, you know,
it's our first con you know, the British come in, George Washington, I beat.
It's why I'm wild times. Everybody's got fumes and full Bush.
Nobody has teeth hygiene. Isn't really a thing. It's one.
And the lives that we've been told about what the American dream is,
it's all based on marketing and it's not real. And the mighty British empire,
none of this stuff that we know is true. It's just nice to read it with
[inaudible]. I was reading this book 1776 by David McCullough.
And I just had a gun in my mouth.
I had a band that like they would use in my throat. I was like,
if I read one more line that I was told, I wouldn't let it fly.
That is the worst part about getting old is when you're like, wait,
everything I learned, I learned in middle school. It's just the lines.
Oh yeah. It's just, yeah. They just making it up to tell school kids about this.
And he's like, Oh, when you do the research, you're like, no,
net is not a thing at all. And it's always about like, like you never like the,
the crazy one to me was I was at a, a world war II Memorial thing, uh,
over the break as well.
And I was just looking at and it was like all about like evil,
Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor and killed like 8,000 troops or 4,000 troops,
whatever it was. And like, just like, like, like levels of like,
just like of a whole building sure. About all that, how bad it was.
And I was like, you guys didn't even mention the 200,000 weekend,
anyone in a minute even mentioned, like,
I feel like if we're going to go four floors worth of Pearl Harbor and be like,
and this is how we retaliated. Yeah. When you win the war,
you write the history and you write the thing. Yeah.
I thought about that. Like, when you think about, you hear all those battles,
like Alexander, the great, you know, conquering the world. And uh,
they say that he was like in the front leading his troops, you're going like,
what is he?
Yeah. Yes. It really up the most valuable man. The King.
Yeah. Like nobody like gets injured in the front.
Like the kids in the front are just walking to their desk.
I think about that all the time.
Every time it was like a mace massive fight scene in a movie.
And it's just like Braveheart or whatever.
Like he couldn't have possibly been in front of you just die in a second. No,
you survive in the backdoor. That's what I like about colonial Americas.
Cause like they, it's kind of a little true there with like, yeah,
George Washington didn't fight. He was at the battles, but way in the back,
like two miles away with the telescope, just be on a magnifying glass.
Just be like, yeah. Okay. Just move that guy over there.
He's the baddest in the whole world. But if you're just surrounded by chaos,
you're going to catch a stray knife in the back or a
[inaudible] nobody's limping back with.
A sprained ankle. It's tough.
It's crazy though. Additions, I slipped in the mud. Would you rather fight.
Like the trenches, uh, world war one the colonial time? Or like, uh, like,
like, Oh, like Braveheart time,
trenches of world war one specifically was brutes boots because I,
the agent orange.
Well, no, well that,
but also like the Doug entrenches where like you would die of like, um,
you know, dysentery guys would die. Like there's, um,
th there's a great documentary called, um, we shall grow old. I believe it is.
And it's colorized, right? Yeah. It's world war one. That's colorized. And then,
and then you FA uh, th the guys would die. A very common thing.
People would die. They would have,
they would be so weak and there was no bathrooms.
It was just like these latrines, these holes, they would,
and they would be rise to the top and they'd be going to the bathroom or puking
and lose energy and drown and sh and.
Cause they couldn't have the energy to get their head out.
Chaps was telling me about like, um, captain Marine who works here. Well,
she is like, he was talking about how they had like, meet like a world war,
one veterans, which obviously there aren't many left.
I don't think there's any left. How it gets done. Right.
I think too is we're winding down on the twos ones down on the twos. Yeah.
The one veterans would have,
like a lot of times they'd have one finger left because it was,
it would be like the pinky or something. Cause they would just, their, their,
their trigger finger would freeze and then just cut it off.
And then they start using this one as a trigger for one from the trenches the
next minute, next one. That's right. Yeah.
It's a pinky to do Coke. Yeah. You want to get some more energy.
So you don't drown in the block. That's the Nazis.
I know world war two is hacked,
but that's what the Nazi's secret weapon wants to pertain. It was crystal meth.
It was, it was modern day. Crystal meth. They would give the soldiers.
That's why a lot of Nazi soldiers when the war was over in the perfect 10
effects, because they last a while they would kind of come to and be like,
what did we do? Why did we do that?
Because he was drugging them and making the super soldier,
like they couldn't be stopped. It was like truly zombie.
What do we do less than they are hung over your way down to 6 million Jews,
genocide damage and rough night. That really like,
whenever you have hangover anxiety, it's like, well,
you want it could've been worse. It happened to me. You want to get a bratwurst?
Can you imagine the fighting after the American revolution.
During the colonial period?
And like you see those kids come with those uniforms, like the red coats,
like stockings on. It's a good strategy though, because like,
you may hesitate to kill him. Cause you're like, those kids look cute.
I don't want to ruin that. Take your shirt off first.
Well put together something. I learned something interesting about that too.
Like just dramatic people in general, Germany,
people have always been business and I'm German,
50% answers.com German people have always been vicious.
The British army hired the Hessians they were called,
and those are German they're from Germany. And so they were just mercenaries.
They were hired to fight and kill Americans. That's what they had. No,
cause in the war, they didn't give a. They were paid to go fight.
So they came off the shores at the battle of Brooklyn.
It's the first time you saw them, they came off the shore,
right where we live in Bay Ridge and started killing American soldiers and then
cutting their heads off and skinning their faces and wearing them as masks.
And the British soldiers were on their server. Like, Whoa, these guys do it.
We just wanted to kill them. And we're moving up. We're taking territory.
They're like happy Halloween. Yikes. Yeah. I, uh,
my high school was built on a hash in mass grave, so, Oh, there you go.
Pretty cool horses in too. There's that hash bloody Lake.
The bloody Lake where it's like all,
because then the Patriots American Patriots started killing them and just
throwing them into this Lake. I forgot.
It's like upstate New York somewhere where it's like a hundred.
Hessians just at the bottom of the Lake.
They just let him just put rocks on them and let them go.
And they believe it's a haunted Lake, which I believe too. I believe he goes.
That's how I learned that. I learned that my high school was built on a hessian,
a mass grave because my hockey coach who lived on campus was watching,
um, a documentary or whatever about the 10,
most haunted places in Rhode Island and his house was number one.
He was like, what the? Oh yeah. England, if you live in new England,
it's haunted.
But that's where the that's where it was a revolutionary war was for new
England. Man. If you're talking about guys who skinned people's faces,
and then they died with, through, into the bottom of the Lake, that's haunting
fat in the headless horseman. You know,
that's a story of that's a hessian soldier. That's
[inaudible] baby.
Yeah. I didn't know that.
I didn't know about them before we started doing the podcast,
but they're interesting to learn about because they wouldn't have how brutal
they were. Like,
if you're in a war and people are talking about how brutal you are
when like everyone's killing everyone, you're like.
Doing some bad, bad shape. Yeah. They were like next level violence.
They were scared to fight. That's why just the presence.
If like there was a common thing in the revolutionary war when they would say
when they would. It's interesting too.
Cause like the biggest prize in the revolutionary war was New Jersey.
That's why they call it like the guard and state.
Cause it was like the garden of America. And now it's like,
that's the first thing I'd give up is New Jersey. I'm like, get the out of here.
Got good to me. They grow tomatoes, tomatoes and corn.
But it's just people from New York and Philly,
just depending on what side of New Jersey you're on. It's like they could,
if we got rid of New Jersey, people just moved back to Philly or New York.
That's what it is.
It comes to Jersey from like outside of the New York or Philly area.
They go on these two sides of people say water really weird.
Really some.
Water and the other one's like, would you like some water?
But, but they would say like when the Hessians would come,
like the soldiers would put their guns down and run away because it was like,
cause if you really want to learn American history, like what the truth is,
then you have to read the other countries. That's what I do.
So the book that I read was about the British point of view or I've read stuff
on the Japanese, on world war two from the Japanese and Germans point of view.
So one, I haven't read a full book. I forget what it was from.
But I was just like the passage about like the people walking out of like
Nagasaki. And it was just like their, like their skin, just like, Oh yeah,
that's brutal. We didn't have to do. I mean, we didn't have to do that,
but we did have to do that. Cause they cause,
cause if you were going to the problem, why the Japanese do not give up.
So you got to give him, those kids do not give up. They keep fighting.
So it was either the options were either kill 2 million,
roughly American troops to invade Tokyo that would kill everybody. That would,
we would win it.
But you're going to cross a lot of allied troops or kill 300,000 of them with a
bomb. So that's what I was all for.
Just nipping that in the bud and wrapping that up.
But at least giving opportunities. And then the second one is the bigger,
like you didn't really have to do.
The second one was kind of like different bond. Like
the second one was the bigger issue. The first one people felt like,
well you're not giving up and you're the war is lost and he was running up the
split. Second one. I was like, come on guy, come on. 30,
run out. Yeah.
It's like in the UFC when the guy's knocked out and then there's that blow that
goes on his unconscious space out Colton.
I have to run it in you to do all that. You know, we just,
we just put your whole country in the microwave. I mean, you know,
you want it to do it again.
You don't need to flip it over the other side of new it again, it's hot.
The hot pocket is done. It came back fast. Oh my God.
It came back with 40 years. I mean,
solid minutes from the Marshall plan that we helped them with. But you know,
but for the most part, yeah, yeah.
They gave him baseball and they ran with it all. Yeah.